alors livres cinéma avec le décès de
monsieur guy roux musique
oui les décadents soit soir vous nous
fait partager un coup de coeur des
français
un coup de coeur que vous avez eu aussi
oui oui un coup de coeur et je trouve
qu'on ne ratera pas j'attends parce
qu'on découvre vraiment sur le tard et
je m'inclus dans le lounge découvert est
à peu près deux ans il s'appelle arman
méliès c'est un auteur compositeur
interprète qui a été un proche
collaborateur de bashô un de mes
préférés surtout en dernier de la pop
star julien doré aussi grillé plus
musiciens ils gagnent vraiment être
connus il avait lancé un album quatrième
disque deux ans un vidéoclip mon plus
bel incendie dans lequel ils assassinent
tous les chanteurs de la chanson
française donc des loges avec intérêts
ils viennent lensois ce très beau disque
plusieurs qualifient cet album de
chefs-d'oeuvre ça s'appelle vertigo je
pense qu'on devrait plus proche en sont
réduits
amen le temps
saucier morts
j'suis est un peu trouble
vous voulez dans le dos
elles sont
halo 2
d
le dfe
donc parfois façon comme du driver et
vous de voir si mu et voilà comme du bon
pain très précisément la chanson swift
morts dans la bande sonore de mac os x
et parfois ça sonne comme vangelis comme
la musique qui le composait pour les
bleus dont on passe du rock
atmosphérique l'électro new wave et il a
une manière de dire les choses à ma
manière
on écrit comme personne au monde mon
plus bel incendie au lieu des 110 et un
couple c'est une relation amoureuse r il
est obsédé par le feu c'est quand même
pas rogner un parolier qui romande
il ya tellement d'obsession avec tout et
incendiaires breizh embrasse-moi volcan
mercure cendres
pompéi incendie j'ai pas trouvé
d'explication mais je suis fasciné par
ce garçon et j'espère que notre voie aux
francofolies l'approché armand méliès à
découvrir vous titre so lu ment je
travaille encore que ce que romain
froment il fait pas les choses comme les
autres ont eu lieu à montréal deux fois
au mois de septembre est filmé un
concert au centre bell qu'il a décidé
mercredi d'offrir gratuitement sur
youtube vous pouvez le regarder
gratuitement sur youtube
quand vous voulez mais aujourd'hui ce
même dvd et commercialiser ce même
concert est commercialisé la différence
est qu'il faudra payer 25 dollars pour
mettre le grappin sur un livret de 80
mais un très beau livre de 80 photos de
cette tournée un croyant qui le met dans
plus de 80 pays
ce lanceur que partout oui sinon c'est
quand même si vous êtes un mégaphone
soit je devrais pas de quoi aller voir
sur youtube moi je n'ai jamais vu en
concert ça manque à ma culture je suis
gêné de le dire oui je sais mais alors
j'ai aimé regarder si on veut regarder
de la faire aussi le juge ne faudrait
tout
montréal te fera aussi
signe de paix
mais des violences eh bien
ce qui fait
imaginez ça va faire le tour du monde on
l'entend dire montréal bell du prix ou
des tribunes espérée durant certains et
moi je regrette de ne pas l'avoir vu en
spectacle si vous y étiez peut-être que
vous allez vous voir beaucoup d' images
de la foule en délire et j'ai été très
impressionné par deux choses d'abord il
est assez autoritaire et chaleureux il
est autoritaire il dirige vraiment son
public qui lui obéit au doigt et à
l'oeil
et quand la caméra est derrière lui et
on voit tout le centre bell play on
réalise à quel point tout ça repose sur
ses épaules
qui est vraiment tout seul ou au centre
de cette grosse aventure
c'est un danseur exceptionnel j'avais
c'est encore plus frappant sur scène
c'est vraiment du concret entre danseurs
privé échangé quelques bouillons peu à
peu ses chances on peut échanger des la
regarder parce qu'on sait pas si vous
retournez sur scène bientôt il y avait
promis qu'elle est peut-être en passe de
3,4
donc pour exciter vos puisque romain la
scène carrée lifebook à d'autres noms
hier l'avocat d'oussouye si ces mots là
je le garde
ça va pas marcher merci la semaine
prochaine dites-nous s'est cassé c'est
au moins mille fois qu'on
fait le droit et
goûter par twitter et
papa ajouté
les papes